this is what happens when you put a
hundred plus hours just into making an
outpost in style field hack oox on the
Starfield subreddit shared this saying
for all you hating on outpost this is
100 plus hours and dedication gets you
and I didn't even know they could look
like this this looks like a city I also
didn't know that they could be this flat
but let me show you the pictures tunnel
bridge over here A bunch of different
buildings by the looks of things look at
it it looks like satisfactory it looks
like a completely different video game
it's like a proper like industrial Mini
City Outpost all these storage
containers it's not exactly a homey
design but it is so much bigger than I
ever expected any of these to get and it
turns out because you actually can't
really build things on a flat surface
you have to like work with whatever
you've given the Creator said that it's
not actually flat he instead worked with
over 3 000 floor mats to get a level
surface which to be clear does also
require mods so you do need mods to get
it done as well